[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
where to even start I was at politican
in Los Angeles over the weekend while
there I appeared on self-described black
conservative Jesse Lee Peterson's
program he as I mentioned on the show
he's against identity politics but he
couches himself as a black conservative
which sounds like it's playing identity
to me identity politics is only bad when
the left does it when the right does it
I don't even think they realize they're
doing it no it's just describing reality
I guess is what he would call it so
we're gonna put the entire interview
online so you can watch it and I
encourage you to watch it my approach
going in was not as usual I can't really
take it seriously because it's all just
so dumb but at the same time I didn't
want to be triggered into escalating
because that sometimes make well in the
past it has made it where Jesse Lee
Peterson kicked me off the show so I
took the approach of remaining as cool
and calm as possible and when he starts
framing questions incorrectly I just
tell him that that's like the one he's
really ignorant about a lot of political
issues but the one thing he does do well
if I were to point out what maybe makes
him successful is he has a way of
framing questions in yes or no format
that is very deceptive and tricky and so
what I committed to internally was not
to allow that to happen the problem is
when you call out his framing of the
questions and that you don't agree with
his premise says you're not answering he
says you're not answering your being
Austin and I think I think his audience
agrees with him of course of course but
I was thinking more for our audience
because his audience is not going to
like what I say no matter what and a
couple interesting things from behind
the scenes one a bunch of the people on
his staff seem to be fans of the David
Pakman show and they were everybody
wanted pictures with me but not in a way
like they were you know sort of like
with the enemy they genuinely seemed to
be fans of the show and I know that he's
based in LA but I think a lot of his
staff is maybe from the south
he's where Jesse Lee Peterson is from I
don't even really know their politics I
don't know if they buy into his entire
you know children of the lie stuff and
Trump is the great white hope or if
they're just kind of like la hipsters I
really couldn't tell but they seemed to
genuinely be fans of the show yeah after
the first two interviews you had with
him you know the second of which he
kicked you off the show he had some
banter back and forth with one of his
producers yeah and the producer was kind
of defending you yes I mean he did admit
that you're evil but you're a different
kind of evil I guess a less evil kind of
evil or something like that
the other interesting thing was his
studio is at I guess I I don't even like
using this term but it's at a Christian
Counseling Center particularly it seems
focused on men so there were all these
pamphlets there where you can go and pay
money obviously and I guess Jesse Lee
Peterson and maybe there's other
so-called counselors on staff and
remember counselors not a regulated term
it's not therapists it's a counselor
they will counsel men about religion and
about their place in the world and all
the stuff can you imagine being in LA
where of course there are thousands and
thousands of good therapists and saying
I'm gonna go and get therapy from Jesse
Lee Peterson for I think it's like a
hundred and fifty bucks an hour or
something like that uh yeah it sounds
pretty counterproductive but at least he
doesn't have to pay any taxes on those
earnings right if he's a good question
Church I don't know if it's a non-profit
I don't know if this is a nonprofit
entity that is interesting so anyway
check out the Jesse Lee Peterson debate
then I did a fake news panel at poetic
on it went really well I was on with
David Brock from Media Matters roaming
millennial who is also I guess her real
name is Lauren she's a Canadian
right-winger Nico Pitney from now this
news and Annie Lenski from the Boston
Globe
all moderated by Sally cone huge
presence of David Pakman show audience
members in the audience when we
introduced ourselves by far my
introduction received the most applause
it was fantastic well I think that's
because some people thought I was also
there on the panel so I said yeah that
true that's a thing that Pat looks like
Sally cone we get that all the time you
know I used to think that
now after meeting her in person I don't
really think that anymore maybe just her
appearance has changed a little over the
last few years now you think that Sally
comb looks like me exactly with that so
that panel went really well then I was
on this should we be socialists panel
with no socialists moderated by Sam
cedar with Ana Kasparian me Bakari
sellers Kyle kolinsky and Marcos mullets
us from DailyKos it was a disaster for
me like I did I did terribly I the
dynamic of it made it very difficult for
me to sort of interject my mic was
significantly so there was like a
problem getting my mic on right before
we even went out there and the guy who
was like the tech guy I was the last
person miked up and he had to put it
together and wire it in like a slightly
different way so the mic also like
wasn't picking me up that well so it was
it was hard to interject in general then
there was a huge back-and-forth between
Kyle kolinsky and Bakari sellers and
Bakari when he would face Kyle would
completely block he couldn't see me
because I was behind him and he blocked
Kyle's view of me there were like three
or four times where I tried to jump in
they just kept talking over me and
because my mic wasn't even set up the
right way it was totally futile like it
was embarrassing I was embarrassed after
it that I'm my participation was like
three or four things like I it couldn't
have gone worse short of being egged
during it or something like that like it
was just it was not a good appearance
for it sounds like mostly circumstances
beyond your control like a poor mic but
you think you told me this earlier if
you had just sat in a different seat
maybe it would have gone better for you
because yeah I wouldn't have been behind
the two people arguing with each other
we went up in a certain order like Sam
and me Bakari Kyle Marcos and we took
chairs in that order which placed me
kind of right in the middle of this of
this line of chairs
I heard to me I should just keep walking
to the end and take the last seat so
then I can kind of turn it and I have
all four other people in front of me
which would be a much more commanding
spot right it would be sort of opposite
the moderator but then I said ah that
might look weird it might look like I
should just take the next chair
available so we have a ben Carson moment
residential debate and I was it was a an
absolute mistake I mean I just should
have taken the chair that seemed to me
like it would have been the right one so
it really didn't go well and afterwards
some people said to me David why didn't
you talk more and I didn't really have a
good answer so I just clearly I mean it
was I considered I consider it a total
failure well I mean I'm just upset that
you didn't get the chance to debate
someone like there were plenty of names
there that would have been an
interesting exchange that you would have
had with them like Charley Kirk or Ben
Shapiro maybe some more than voting
Dennis Rodman there are so many
conservatives I'd like to see you go up
against so a few behind the scenes
things Dennis Rodman was not the most
approachable guy a couple people I know
started to kind of approach him to just
say hire a picture any kind of like he
waved them on with his hands that kind
of pushed to push them away so they
wouldn't even talk to him spoke to dr.
drew for a little bit he went to Amherst
College near where the David Pakman show
started so we reminisced about some of
the restaurants in the area and when I
was labeled a former neo-nazi on his
headline news program oh yeah really
really nice guy I had a long
conversation with Karger page and I
posted a picture of me with Carter page
to my Instagram account and you can
check that out at David Pakman he is a
genuinely nice guy but something does
seem a little off about him and he truly
believes like everything he said on the
show the dirty dossier or the dodgy
dossier I think he called it about the
Christopher Steele document and how he's
he hasn't done anything wrong and it's
all just kind of like trumped up and the
wiretaps against him are illegal every
single thing he said on the show he said
to me in private and he believes so the
good news is he's not putting on a
persona when he appears on the show the
bad news is he genuinely seems sort of
that disconnected from reality
yeah we've kind of identified him or a
suspected him of being a useful idiot
and which is the term that's not a
pejorative but it certainly can come
across as one yes and it's just too bad
that you can't really ask him if he
thinks he fits that role because now I'm
across as insulted but I did say to him
when we took a picture I said no mug
shots because you're not going to prison
and sort of referencing how in the
interview he had said I there's no
reason I would go
Prison and he said no I'm not and I said
to him listen it seems like you I don't
agree with you about any of this stuff
but it does seem like you're sincere in
your beliefs at least as you presented
them and he said yeah why wouldn't I be
the other thing about Carter page that
was interesting is so political had a
lot of security they had it was there
was all sorts it was politicans staff
and then there was venue security and
then like the really big names came with
their own security like when Kathy
Griffin showed up looking very odd by
the way she had her own security in
addition Carter there were these two
security guys who didn't really seem to
be Carter pages security like I think
they were venue security but they were
always right in the background when I
was talking to Carter page and it seemed
like maybe the event had told security
to kind of keep an eye on Carter page
yeah he's not the most recognizable
figure but maybe at an event like
Politico and he is hmm those people
could also be Russian agents though so
watch out for that that was in the most
interesting part of the conversation I
said to him when you're here at a place
like this do you imagine that there are
like fake audience members or whatever
like do you imagine that you're being
surveilled here and he said you mean
like the intelligence community and I
said yes and he said no he said he
doesn't really go around like he he's
aware of when he was wiretapped and
apparently that's over or maybe it's not
but that his concern is more like
electronic surveillance he doesn't
assume that he said if he's at an event
like that but there are plants in the
audience who are actually members of the
intelligence community
all right yeah did you enjoy did you
attend any of those debates like the
classic Jenk versus tucker carlson
square off or han [ __ ] versus charlie
kirk so I flew back before the Jenk
tucker carlson won what I saw a few
minutes of it online I did go to about
five or ten minutes of the Hasan [ __ ]
versus charlie kirk debate if you don't
know who those people are
congratulations I mean it was just
yelling back and forth at one point
Charlie Kirk and Genki ogre who was in
the audience in his Hassan's uncle got
into a back-and-forth which was
interesting I wasn't there for that I
did meet at that debate this guy from
the Stoneman Douglas
school school Kyle cashews who is like
the right-wing alternative of David hog
David hog became an activist from the
Stoneman Douglas mass shooting for gun
safety and in Kyle khushu became like
his right-wing counterpart who met with
Trump and Melania and his for gun rights
and he came up and said hi to me and
said he was familiar with the show nice
Katie I mean 17 years old you know but
certainly very precocious I won't I
won't deny that but you know the one
thing is everybody is pretty friendly
they're like the right and left wingers
James Carville was there talking to
right-wingers and chris Christie was
hanging out backstage talking to left
wingers and everybody just kind of gets
along which i think is predictable yeah
we were we were worried that politican
is cancer in the sense that it's just
kind of like portrayed as the Superbowl
of politics yeah and you show up there
wanting to debate people and get the
best of them right sounds like at least
backstage there wasn't much of that no
it was really pretty friendly and I
think I must have taken 200 pictures
with different people who some travelled
as far as from Australia to see my
participation in Politico so it was a
really great event now I heard you also
have some incident yeah that weekend I
was thinking maybe on Sbarro's boenish
okay give the audience something to
sleep on come back then they'll hear
about my weekend what is it like can you
give a general sense of what type of
story it is or what it relates to it
involves syringes a laundry room and
threats of violence okay am I would I be
off if I suggest that it's related to
the opioid epidemic of the Boston area
no that's correct it is correct okay all
right well so we'll hear from Pat about
that story tomorrow sounds like a sad
story as much as an interesting one
usually anything involving the opioid
epidemic in Boston is pretty sad so we
will start uploading some of the stuff
from Politico and the Jesse Lee Peterson
interview and all of this over the next
few days look forward to hearing from
people
we'll be back with a new show and new
bonus show tomorrow the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]